welcome to build with google cloud where
we build things reference architectures
that can help you make your google cloud
journey a little bit easier
[Music]
imagine you are a cloud architect for
food.com an internet accessible
application there are many different
ways to architect such an application on
google cloud no one way is right or
wrong i'm priyanka vergaria developer
advocate here at google cloud and today
i'm going to walk you through one such
way you ready let's go
[Music]
let's say our internet-facing
application is foo.com and our users are
accessing it by typing food.com in the
browser what happens next we've written
code for this application and deployed
it on a web server initially let's say
our application is decently popular with
minimal functionality and this one
server is enough to handle the traffic
our users will access this application
at food.com but how would the request
reach to the web server
on the internet every single device has
an ip address which other devices use to
communicate with each other
the request from the user's computer
goes to the dns server which responds
back with an ip address that is used by
the user's computer to then make a
connection to our web server
great but our website also has some
business logic for that we add an
additional application server to handle
some back-end processing such as
authentication servers inventory payment
services and things like that
then comes the database now every modern
web application leverages one or more
databases to store information
it could be a relational or
non-relational database depending on the
type of data and the use case
let's come back to that in just a little
bit
now let's say our app becomes really
popular and the one server we have is
just not enough we need to scale our
servers to handle the increased traffic
we have two options here we could either
scale vertically by increasing the size
of our machines giving it more memory
and more cpu or we could scale
horizontally by adding more servers to
the equation
you will find that scaling horizontally
or scaling out is almost always a good
idea because it gives you more
flexibility with vertical scaling we
reach a limit at a certain point beyond
which we really won't be able to add any
more memory or cpu and at that point you
will have to scale horizontally i would
like to know if you've tried scaling an
application vertically or horizontally
and how it went
what was the use case and why did you
make that choice of scaling up or out
now we have more than one server we also
have more than one ip addresses for
these servers so we need something to
balance the load to our servers that's
where load balancer comes in it
distributes the traffic to the servers
there are lots of different algorithms
that load balancer can be set up for
such as round robin where routing to the
server will be in a cyclic pattern or
global where traffic would be routed
based on where it's coming from for
example a request from asia is sent to
the server in asia now weighted load
balancing is based on load and
performance for example if a load on the
server reaches say 70
send traffic to another one and you can
add a combination of bunch of these
rules we also add an internal load
balancer that does the same for our
internal application servers
now let's focus our attention on the
database for applications with heavy
transaction processing where you need to
ensure that the transactions are
accurate consistent isolated and durable
also called acid relational databases
should be used relational databases or
also called sql databases store data in
tables you have the predefined schema
prior to filling the table and the
tables are linked with each other
through keys
for applications that require analysis
of data non-relational databases have
emerged to handle massive amounts of
data and process it to generate really
meaningful insights out of them
most nosql databases can scale
horizontally what kind of database are
you using in your application and why
you made that choice
i would love to know share with me in
the comments when it comes to scale we
also reduce load on the database for the
frequently accessed data for this reason
relational databases leverage in-memory
database cache so the app servers don't
hit the database for every single
request rather those requests are served
from the database cache such as
memcached or redis now the next part of
the equation is media files we typically
never save our images video files and
static content on the web and
application service such object files
are better stored in an external blob
storage
we usually save the metadata for those
objects as the database and the file is
in the external storage your mobile
devices will need a different image size
and resolution than your desktop app or
you can serve videos that need
transcoding for that sort of processing
logic you write a function code that
triggers every time a file gets uploaded
into your storage
now consider this if a file is
frequently accessed say a popular video
or an image on the website and your
users are distributed globally
then you don't want to access the file
every time from the external storage you
would rather want to cache the file
closer to the user for lower cost low
latency and overall better performance
additionally there might be push or
email notifications that you need to
send to the user for certain things
for those we can use an asynchronous
messaging service push notifications in
it and then have a service subscribe to
that queue to send those notifications
out to users through another service
next part of the puzzle is analytics we
usually have two types of data to ingest
into the analytics system
the real-time data and the batch data
the real-time could be content from
servers such as click stream data or
from iot devices sensors the batch data
could be from your logs these are just
examples
what types of real-time and batch data
are you collecting for analytics and
processing let's discuss more in the
comments
once the data is ingested we process and
enrich it to clean it up and make it
ready for downstream systems
then store it in a data warehouse for
further analysis now data warehouse is a
storage where you keep processed data
the data from our databases could also
be aggregated processed and saved in the
data warehouse for further analysis you
might have heard the term etl extract
transform and load that's what that is
but etl is usually applied to batch data
now data analysts then analyze the data
and create dashboards for broader
consumption and then data scientists in
your machine learning teams can pick up
that data from the data warehouse and
use it for creating machine learning
models to generate predictions you could
also directly ingest data from storage
systems for the ml models the term that
i did not describe here is data lake do
you know what it is and where does it
fit in this puzzle drop it in the
comments and i'll chime into the
discussion back to our application we
also need to make sure we holistically
monitor our servers and every part of
the architecture
and we need to make sure all this is
secure in a private network use a
firewall to ensure that the servers that
should not be exposed to the public
internet are not and the ones that
should talk to each other can
we also need to make sure that
developers have the right access to
build the apps devops teams have the
access to deploy them and data analysts
have access to analyze the data and
other such access related rules around
application security data security and
infrastructure security now if you were
a cloud architect for food.com how would
you translate this architecture onto
google cloud there are so many different
ways of achieving the same goal no one
way is right or wrong
let me show you one of my approaches but
i would love to know how you would do it
i'm sure your approach is another unique
one that everyone watching would benefit
from so share it in the comments and
i'll chime in if you comment in the
first seven days
the first thing is to create a virtual
private cloud which provides managed
networking functionality for all of our
google cloud resources for our
application infrastructure the web and
app servers we have multiple options
depending on multiple factors if i have
got a small team of developers their
time is better spent coding and not
worrying about infrastructure and
scaling tasks serverless options such as
cloud run app engine would be great
picks both are serverless and scale with
no effort as your traffic grows cloud
run offers the ability to run serverless
containers not just supporting web
traffic but also web sockets and grpc
if we want to run containerized apps but
with more configuration and flexibility
then we would pick google kubernetes
engine it helps us deploy containerized
apps with kubernetes without much of a
learning curve while giving us the
control over configuration of nodes that
we want in our infrastructure
gke also offers autopilot for when you
need the flexibility and control but
have limited ops and engineering support
the maximum control option is compute
engine it is straight up virtual
machines so we can define the
configuration of our machines depending
on what the amount of memory and cpu we
need but this control also means more
responsibility to scale manage patch and
maintain them as needed my
recommendation would be to use compute
engine for legacy applications or
applications that require high cpu and
memory with specific needs and
situations that truly require full
control
because you will need a bigger better
operations team to manage which of these
compute options are you using today and
what do you like about it i would love
to know share with me in the comments
now comes the time when we need to
balance load across our compute choices
cloud load balancing is a fully
distributed software defined system it
can literally respond to over a million
queries per second and is based on any
cast ip address
what does that mean well it means that
we can define our front-end
infrastructure with a single ip address
if we had global users coming from say
asia u.s europe it can serve requests
from a server that is as close to them
as possible
it also offers internal load balancing
for our internal application servers so
we can route traffic amongst them as
needed right at the load balancer we
have an option to enable cloud cdn to
cache the frequently requested media and
web content closer to the user at the
nearest edge location
this reduces latency and optimizes for
last mile performance for our users it
also saves cost by fielding the request
right at the edge without needing to
send it to the backend
and cloud cdn would be caching content
that is stored in cloud storage our
object store where we store all of our
media assets css javascript images
basically everything static in nature
now cloud dns is google's infrastructure
for high volume authoritative dns
serving which offers 100 sla meaning it
never goes down it uses our global
network of anycast name servers to serve
the dns zone from the redundant location
around the world providing that high
availability and the lower latency for
the users this media processing function
can be deployed on cloud functions which
is serverless function as a service that
scales as needed and can be triggered
from cloud storage and any other service
for asynchronous messaging service we
would use pub sub and send messages to a
topic and then the service could
subscribe to that topic to receive those
messages and send out those
notifications and do other things with
it if needed
now coming to databases we have a few
choices here for relational databases we
have cloud sql and spanner they are both
managed for generic sql needs mysql
postgres and sql server cloud sql is
perfect
spanner is best for massive scale
relational database that needs
horizontal scaling
by massive i mean thousands of writes
per second and tens of thousands of read
per second and while doing so it really
also supports strong consistency and
asset transactions i would say you use
spanner when you need benefits of both
relational and non-relational databases
for non-relational databases we have
three major options firestore bigtable
and memory store firestore is a
serverless document database that can be
used as database as a service which is
easy to set up and provides fast results
to complex queries in real time it also
supports offline data and syncs which
makes it a great choice for mobile use
cases along with web iot and gaming
now bigtable on the other hand is a wide
column nosql database that supports
heavy reads and writes with extremely
low latency this makes it a perfect
choice for events time series data from
iot devices click stream
event fraud
recommendations and other
personalization related use cases
memory store is a fully managed
in-memory data store service for redis
and memcached at google cloud it is best
for in-memory and transient data stores
and automates the complex tasks of
provisioning replication failover and
patching so you can spend more time
coding
because it offers extremely low latency
and high performance memory store is
great for web and mobile gaming
leaderboard social chat news feeds types
of application along with in-memory
database caches i would love to know
which database options you're using
share with me in the comments
now comes the analytics piece we can
ingest the batch data from cloud storage
and real-time data from the applications
using pub sub which is serverless
messaging service that scales to ingest
millions of events per second dataflow
can be used for processing and enriching
the batch and streaming data it is based
on open source apache beam you could use
dataprep instead for processing if you
are looking to do the transformations
with the ui in a no code fashion
but if you're in a hadoop ecosystem then
dataproc would be a better choice for
processing it is managed hadoop and
spark platform that sets up to analyze
the data faster instead of learning
about managing and standing up your
hadoop cluster
we just need to change that hdfs link to
point to cloud storage and everything
else just works exactly the same as it
would on your hadoop cluster
bigquery is a serverless data warehouse
that supports sql queries and can scale
to petabytes of data it can also act as
your long-term storage and a data leak
we can run sql queries to analyze our
data within bigquery and it literally
queries over petabytes of data and
responds in seconds due to underlying
separation of that storage from compute
that's needed to run that query we can
use this data from bigquery to create a
dashboard in looker or data studio it
also offers machine learning
capabilities so we can create ml models
and make predictions by just writing
some sql statements so all in all
bigquery is amazing if we want we can do
all our data analytics with just
bigquery do you do that let me know in
the comments now for machine learning
and ai projects we can use the data in
bigquery to train our models in vertex
ai or we can import our media files
images and other unstructured data sets
from cloud storage as well
mlai our options depend really on
whether we want to create our own custom
models or use pre-trained models my
recommendation is to always start with a
pre-trained model see if it works for
you
most common use cases are all covered
including the images text videos and
tabular data if a pre-trained model
really does not work for your use case
then you can use the auto ml version
within vertex ai to train a custom model
on your own data set again you'll be
doing less coding in this case auto ml
supports all your common use cases in
case you have lots of ml and data
science experience in-house that is only
when i would say write your own custom
model code in the frameworks of your
choice tensorflow pytorch whatever you
choose next for operations monitoring
debugging and troubleshooting cloud
operations suite offers all the tools
that you need to troubleshoot when it
comes to security understand that
security in cloud is a shared
responsibility google cloud offers those
inherent infrastructure security and
tools that you would need to protect
your application your data and your
software
now how do you make sure your data is
secure
well data is always encrypted at rest
and in transit when on google cloud you
can use confidential computing vms to
also encrypt data in use for sensitive
workloads
you can also bring your own custom keys
for encryption and there are multiple
options for that with key management
service where you can manage your own
keys in google cloud you can use
external key manager or hardware
security model for data loss prevention
and protecting pii information you have
dlp which helps mask and tokenize
sensitive data in bigquery cloud storage
or even on-prem
how do you make sure the right users
have the right access
for user authentication you have cloud
identity which checks if the user is who
they say they are and for authorization
you have cloud iam where you can define
who has access to what
how do you make sure your applications
are secure
for an application like food.com which
is an internet-facing application the
application security and api security
solution is provided where you can use
recaptcha for generating a token
recapture enterprise deciphers the token
in the incoming request and then
enforces or allows or denies the
decisions in cloud armor if cloud armor
allows the request then it is forwarded
to load balancer and load balancer then
sends the request to a respective
backend with apigee api gateway in the
middle which allows or denies or routes
api calls based on client credentials
and quotas
how do you monitor your systems for
security well security command center
continuously monitors your google cloud
environment for visibility into the
system it discovers vulnerabilities it
detects threats and then shows that so
you can take action on them
there's a lot more in security that i'm
not covering here let me know which
topics you would like to learn more in
the comments
now how does cicd work as a developer i
would write the code for an application
i can use cloud code within ide push the
code to cloud build which then packages
and tests it runs vulnerability scans on
it binary authorization then checks for
trusted images and once the tests are
passed it deploys the package to staging
using cloud deploy from there you can
create a process to review and promote
the application to production
in case of containers the container
images are stored in artifact registry
from where they can be deployed to gke
or cloud run
if you stuck around this far then
congratulations you just learned most of
the google cloud services for networking
compute
storage
databases data analytics machine
learning ai
security operations cicd there is
definitely a lot more to explore but i'm
confident this will get you started with
the right background
now it's your turn go build something
and share with me in the comments
if you like this video then i hope you
completely destroy those like and
subscribe buttons to let me know i
cannot wait to build more stuff with you
[Music]
[Music]